i'm delighted to announce that today
after years of discussion
g7 finance ministers have reached a
historic agreement to reform the global
tax system
to make it fit for the global digital
age but crucially to make sure that it's
fair so that the right companies pay the
right tax in the right places
and that's a huge prize for british
taxpayers
it's a it's a very proud moment and i
want to say thank you to my g7
colleagues for their collective
leadership and for their willingness to
work together
to seize this moment to reach a historic
agreement that
finally brings our global tax system
into the 21st century
can you give people a sense of what this
actually means you know the rates we're
talking about the mechanisms we're
talking about it's complicated but
you know this is important stuff yeah it
you know it's complicated and this is
the first step this is agreement
amongst g7 finance ministers and next
month we'll have a g20
finance minister summit to make further
progress but i think the crucial thing
for people to take away is
the principle of fairness that's what
we've achieved today to ensure that
there's a level playing field for all
types of companies
and whether it's people operating in tax
havens or as digital companies we're
going to level the playing field
and inject that principle of fairness
into our global tax system that's the
price
at the moment the uk has a digital
services tax already
um what will happen now that these rules
are potentially coming into play will
they potentially raise even more money
than that digital services tax for you
know uk public spending and will you get
rid of that digital services tax
uh in future well we've always said that
the digital services tax that we've
implemented as have many others whether
that's france italy spain
canada soon all of those are meant to be
temporary solutions until we found a
multilateral agreement on this issue
that could be implemented consistently
across the world now so this is the
first step g7 agreement we've got to
move to the g20 and then beyond
but obviously the intention would be
once there is a global multilateral
solution in place then the need for
those dsts falls away
and how do you square a global minimum
corporate tax rate with
the importance of tax sovereignty i mean
aren't you potentially tying your own
hands if you have this minimum rate
in future well i think what the british
public want to know is that the tax
system is fair they want to know that
there is a level playing field so
whether people are operating in tax
havens
or whether large particularly online
businesses are able to
not pay tax in the right places they
want that tackled and that's what this
agreement
gives us the ability to do and it's been
agreed
amongst g7 colleagues and once we've
broadened it out and implement it
globally it's a huge prize for british
taxpayers it's slightly
slightly less ambitious than the
original proposal that global minimum
not 21
but 15 does that undermine you know the
strength of this agreement some people
suggest it does
well i'd say a couple of things first of
all what the agreement reached here
today says at least
15 and secondly it's worth taking a step
back this is something that's been
talked about for
almost a decade and here for the first
time today we actually have
agreement on the tangible principles of
what these reforms should look like
and that's huge huge progress final
question if i may the prime minister
said just uh recently that he'd been
looking at the data and he saw no reason
why uh there shouldn't be a change to
that plan june the 21st for
ending lockdown you obviously look at
the data an awful lot as well i just
wonder what your senses
of what that data's saying at the moment
with regard to lockdown well no final
decisions have been made we're looking
at the data as it as it comes in and as
the prime minister said
you know we need to make sure that we
vaccinated
and protected enough people to give us a
reassurance we need
given the new variant that is currently
in the uk
and it's too early to say where that
will conclude but as the data comes in
we're looking at it and a decision will
be made
as we've communicated in advance of june
21st okay